choisis bon alors quel serait le métier
idéal pour que pour une fois les gens
aient envie de m'écouter et c'est là que
j'ai l'idée de monter sur scène alors
j'ai utilisé la Belgique je suis parti à
Paris j'ai commencé d'abord à passer des
tas de casting pour jouer dans des
pièces mais bon là malheureusement
ils ont pas trouvé que j'étais une bonne
comédienne enfin non le directeur du
casting a dit bonne oui comédienne non
mais il a dit bon ça s'appelle
s'arranger si tu veux on va boire un
verre et un en discute donc on est allé
dans un café on s'est assis il a dit
qu'est-ce que tu vas prendre j'ai dit un
jus d'orange il a dit c'était pas une
question
bon bah du coup
ben j'ai rien vu
puis là il a dit qu'il voulait quand
même bien me donner un rôle dans une
pièce
sa chambre à coucher
alors moi j'ai fait une petite blague
j'ai dit comme ça
je dis oh là là on dirait une pièce dans
laquelle on s'endort
[Musique]
comme vous il est à Paris
il a dit je vais te donner un conseil
très très important pour ta carrière
dans ce métier il faut coucher si tu
veux avoir une chance de réussir enfin
pour certaines
alors
il faut réussir pour avoir une chance de
coucher enfin pour certains
non il a été très vexé
il m'a grillé dans toute la profession
du théâtre donc
je suis rentrée chez moi désespéré en
plus quand je racontais tout ça à mon
père il était scandalisé il comprenait
pas qu'on puisse comme ça me proposer de
coucher pour avoir un rôle et que moi je
refuse
il m'a dit il m'a dit tu sais le showbiz
j'étais comme les toboggans à la piscine
on avance plus vite quand on se couche
même si parfois ça fait mal au cul
heureusement après il a quand même
ajouté bon maintenant si tu veux y
arriver par toi-même en travaillant dur
tout en restant honnête je peux
comprendre mais en tout cas sache que ta
mère et moi on serait très fier que tu
suces Michel Drucker
et là j'ai j'ai eu une révélation je me
suis dit si mes parents peuvent avoir
assez confiance en la vie pour croire
que Michel Drucker est encore capable de
bander
et ben moi aussi je vais encore en vie
et on est capacité